[Music]
i don't want the events of this past
week to overshadow
one good thing that happened we ended
2020
and started a new year now i know 2021
isn't exactly
perfect so far but every day of last
year felt like being hit in the head
with the dull hammer over and over and
over with no end in sight
oh come on it wasn't all bad i know you
well enough to know that you can see the
good in everything
even a year like 2020. well i
guess there were some good things that
happened
hit it
[Music]
20 20 what a year so full of crushing
sorrow we counted down the days until we
found a new tomorrow
the time has come for 21 and 20s finally
ended
but it would be a lie to say that some
things were not splendid
we all got into tiger king that looks at
our affections and who could forget
donald trump lost the election
and there's uh the
the other thing that happened is uh
there's a okay hugo oh oh okay
uh okay oh i got it um
i really like the last hands because
basketball is cool
and trump plus the election made himself
look like a fool
i already said that right yeah we made
this
song way too long i thought we'd have
more things
and the election's really the big one
uh-huh so no
oh parasite won best picture that was
the same year
yeah february crazy right how about that
yeah and who can forget when donald
trump lost the election
wow okay we really recorded that backup
vocal thinking we would get this far
without mentioning it certainly did
oh i like that one song what's up i
can't remember what it's called uh
it was like um oh
i can't with the music i can't think uh
can we stop the music
it should end soon now break it down
y'all oh
oh no all right yeah cut the music gosh
we got way too cracky
20 20 wasn't good for [ __ ] oh and you
know i didn't even
really like the tiger king that much
either oh
i didn't like it i'm still worried about
all those poor exploited tigers
that was a dark time yeah hey what was
the song you were thinking of
oh i had the wrong gear um it was hey
yeah
oh good talk wait wait don't go anywhere
i have big news i have my own youtube
channel now
yay be sure to subscribe for a lot of
show clips and a lot of digital
exclusives
and a lot of this see you there
[Applause]
[Music]